مع من يشعر الانسان بالراحه مع اهله مع
اسرته مع اصدقائه مع من يحب لكن يا راويه
العلاقات الاكثر سمي وفق دراسه جديده تقول
تاتيك من المقربين اللي يساعدونك احيانا
ويودونك في احيان اخرى مثلا الصديق السام
او المدير الذي يمارس ضغطا غير منطقي عليك
هذه الدراسه مشاهدينا اشارت اليها صحيفه
نيويورك انه العلاقات المتناقضه يمكن ان
تضر بصحتك فالبالغون يعانون من ارتفاع ضغط
الدم وارتفاع معدلات ضربات القلب بعد
التفاعل عاده مع الاشخاص الذين اثاروا
مشاعر مختلطه اكثر من التفاعل مع اولئك
الناس الذين اثروا مشاعر سلبيه حتى تخيلوا
الدراسات اوضحت ان القاء التحيه على نفسه
الشخص الذي يجرحك لا يخفف من المشاعر
السيئه اللي في داخلك بل يضخمها ويترك
اثرا في قلبك وفي دمك ايضا
[موسيقى]
شيء شيء بطاقه هذا الانسان كمان
في طاقه سلبيه في احساس دائما عنده هو انه
ما في خيارات كثيره وكانه للعلم لما نتكلم
عن السميه بنتكلم عن اضطرابات شخصيه يعني
من بعيد خلينا نقول محمد
كيف انا استطيع ان اكمل المشوار مع علاقه
اشعر فيها بالسميه العاليه من قبل الطرف
الاخر بس مضطر اني اكمل هلا في بعض
الاقتراحات اولا بده نسعى للتغيير بمعنى
انه يوضح ان هناك مشكله وهذا الكلام بده
مرات تدخل قد يكون طرف خارج سواء كان مرشد
نفسي
في طرف ثالث الان توضيح ان هناك في مشكله
في التواصل وتكون واضحه الامور بمعنى
الحديث عن السميه يعني ما راح نقول له انت
سام لكن حنقول انه الانتقاد المتواصل ترى
مؤذي التدقيق على بعض الامور بشكل سلبي مش
مريح
في ناس سلبيه ولكن برضه عندهم كثير صفات
جيده واحنا مش حابين نخسرهم من حياتنا
ولكن مش مضطرين على هاي العلاقه ولكن بنحب
انها تكون موجوده بحياتنا فكيف بنقدر نحط
حد للجزء السيء اللي اللي بياثر علينا
سلبا ونخلي الجزء الجميل من هذه العلاقه
في التحمل بدك ترفعي سقف التحمل